the last
talk of the day will be given by
alex vine who from current new york
and he will give us an introduction on
the low degree polynomial method
uh great thanks a lot and uh thanks to
the
organizers um for having me
um all right so i'll be talking about
this
method the low degree polynomial method
for predicting and understanding
uh computational statistical gaps
um i hope this is supposed to be sort of
a pedagogical talk so i hope
to go slow and make this understandable
to everyone so please do
interrupt me and ask questions if
anything is
not clear
okay so the talk will be in four short
parts
the first part is uh i want to tell you
what is this low degree method and why
you should care about it so
for motivation i want to talk about
problems in high dimensional statistics
so maybe an example that we've
all heard of is this question of finding
a large clique in a random graph
so a clique being this fully connected
sub graph shown in red
and there's a bunch of different
variants of this problem that you can
think about
the first is called detection so in
detection i give you a graph that's
either
just a random graph or it's a graph with
a pointed clique in it
and you have to decide which it was in
the recovery problem i give you a graph
with a planted clique and you have to
find the clique
and then finally the optimization
problem is where i give you a random
graph
that has no planted clique and you just
have to find the
largest as larger clique as possible
and as we know these types of problems
can often have information computational
gaps so for example when planted clique
if k is the size of the clique
we know that the problem is impossible
when k is smaller than 2 log n
because 2 log n is the size of the
biggest naturally occurring clique in a
graph
in a random graph but in polynomial time
we only know how to find
a clique of size bigger than squared of
n
and so there's this elusive hard region
in the middle where
statistically it's possible if you want
to check all the cliques but
we don't know an efficient algorithm and
so the high level goal of this line of
work is to sort of understand what makes
problems easy versus hard
so what is this low degree polynomial
method well it is a
framework for understanding these types
of
computational complexity issues
so historically speaking this originated
from the sum of squares
hierarchy this first paper here
is the so-called pseudo-calibration
approach
and then the other papers stated the
idea kind of of low degree polynomials
more explicitly but in this talk i want
to motivate all of this in a
self-contained way
without really talking about sum of
squares
so it's worth mentioning that what i'm
talking about today is is distinct from
sum of squares although there are
connections between the two
um and if you want to know more about
the conjecture connections you could
look at
sam hopkins phd thesis
so the idea of this method is to study a
restricted class of algorithms
which as you can guess will be low
degree polynomials
so what do i mean for a low degree
polynomial to be an
algorithm um well i'm imagining
a polynomial that takes in you know maps
from r to the n
to some r to the m so really it
is a if you like a tuple of m different
polynomials
f1 through uh f
m and each one each individual one
goes from rn
to r
right then these are multivariate
polynomials and so you imagine the input
being just whatever input i'm given to
my problem
so for planted clique i imagine taking
in the whole graph
the whole adjacency matrix as the input
so n choose two different variables
as the output well it depends a little
bit on the setting but for example i
could imagine the output being just a
zero one value
if i want to distinguish between two
possibilities
um more realistically we'll allow a bit
of leeway and really
have it be either close to zero or close
to one
or i could ask the output to be some
vector maybe the indicator vector for
the position of the clique
and here when i say low degree i mean
the degree
typically should be logarithmic in the
dimension
uh okay so why do we care about these
types of algorithms
many uh you know well-known algorithms
turn out to be
low degree so for instance uh if i
imagine
the input is a matrix
one thing you can do is power iteration
so maybe start with the all one vector
and multiply this by your matrix
a bunch of times this is a good way to
approximate the top
eigenvector of your matrix another thing
you can do is
if you instead want to get the top
eigenvalue
you can raise your matrix to a high
power and get the index of trace
so this will be an approximation of you
know the maximum eigenvalue
raised to the k uh and typically it
takes
uh you know logarith uh case should be
about log n for these types of methods
to work
another example is the approximate
message passing framework so this has
been
uh hugely successful in
giving optimal solutions to all sorts of
problems
so here you typically alternate between
doing
a step of powder power iteration and
doing some kind of non-linear
transformation and you do this uh
a constant number of times
and the final one is local algorithms on
sparse graphs
meaning you have like a graph with
constant average degree and
each node gets to look at some
neighborhood of constant radius and
make some kind of local decision
or finally you can do any of these
things applied to some
pre-transformation of your graph
so uh right first build some other
matrix based
based on your data and then do power
iteration on that
so that captures these more
sophisticated spectral methods
such as the non-backtracking walk matrix
or the
tensor unfolding uh and so on
so alex there is a question uh from
galena that perhaps to make it quicker
how does lambda max method work to find
the click
um okay good to find the so one way you
can find
if you wanted to just distinguish
between having a clique
versus not a clique one way you could
try to do this would be by taking the
top eigenvalue
of your adjacency matrix
and it's possible to show that if there
is a big planted clique
this will cause the eigenvalue to be
large larger than it would be for just a
random graph
elena i i made you i am muted you so if
you want to
does this answer the question uh i guess
it's just too long to explain in more
detail so so yes thank you
okay
um okay so the claim that i want to make
today
is that low degree polynomials provide a
unified explanation
for comp information computational gaps
in a bunch of different settings
namely this detection recovery and
optimization variants that i talked
about before
so more specifically for all of these um
long list of kind of our favorite
problems from high dimensional
statistics
it is the case that first of all the
best known
polynomial time algorithms are in fact
low degree
specifically one of these three types i
talked about
to clarify this a bit i'm not saying
that every optimal algorithm
can be made low degree sometimes there
are good algorithms such as convex
programming or mcmc that are not
obviously low degree but what i'm saying
is that
in all these cases if we know some
algorithm that works then we also know a
low degree algorithm that works
um and furthermore we can often prove
that low degree polynomials fail in the
hard regime
and so this has motivated what we
sometimes call the low degree conjecture
which is sort of the informal idea that
low degree polynomials are as powerful
as all
polynomial time algorithms for a certain
uh quote natural class of these high
dimensional
problems which i won't try to define
formally
but one formal version of this
conjecture appears in sam hopkins thesis
and so the point of this talk will be
that i want to show you some techniques
to prove that all low-degree polynomials
fail to solve a certain problem of
course if we can do this this gives
concrete evidence that the problem is
computationally hard
and i will talk about it in three
different these three different settings
so based on some of these references
here
okay um so that was kind of the overview
so now let's
jump in and talk about the first setting
which is detection
uh unless there are any other questions
so what is detection here we are trying
to hypothesis tests
between two possibilities we want to
succeed with
error probability little of one
and we usually have some null model
which for instance you can think of
being just a random graph g
and one half a random graph where each
edge occurs with probability of half
and then we also have the planted model
which is where you have
some kind of planted structure so think
of it as a random graph
with some k clique randomly hidden
somewhere
and what's the idea we want to ask
whether there is a degree d polynomial
that takes in say the whole matrix the
whole adjacency matrix
and outputs just one number and we want
this to distinguish
between p and q in the sense that we
wanted to output something big if we're
in the
if the sample if the graph came from the
planted distribution and output
something small
if the graph came from the null
distribution
so specifically i want to compute this
thing which i'll call the
advantage so it's the maximum over
degree d polynomials because we want to
find the best polynomial
and it's like the mean of the mean in
the planted distribution
divided by the fluctuations in the null
distribution
right so this is sort of a measure of
how well you can hypothesis test
and if this value blows up to infinity
as n goes to infinity
we'll say that degree d polynomials
succeed and if
instead this remains bounded we'll say
that degree d
polynomials fail so for now i want to
think of this as just being the
definition of what it means for
polynomials to succeed or fail
you can of course wonder a bit about
whether this is uh
you know if this is small does that
really rule out
you know thresholding a low degree
polynomial as a test or something
and it turns out that uh yes this can be
shown
in some sense that if this thing is
bounded you can you can show in a more
formal sense that
thresholding a low degree polynomial
will not
work although this is subject to a few
mild technical conditions that i won't
get into
at the moment um okay and what type of
result are we hoping to prove
here well here's just sort of an example
for planted clique
so remember in this k is the size of the
clique and
k equals square root n is sort of the
conjectured threshold for hardness
so this first bullet point is saying
that if k is bigger than root n
then the advantage blows up to infinity
meaning that low degree polynomials
succeed
whereas on the other hand if k is
smaller than root n then
the advantage remains bounded meaning
that low degree polynomials fail
um for any degree that's uh here
logarithmic
um one sort of more fine-grained
question you can ask
is whether this degree here can be
improved
right maybe we can hope to rule out even
higher degree polynomials just to be
safe
and indeed sometimes we can do that for
instance you could rule out
polynomials of degree n to the delta
and this actually has sort of a natural
interpretation
because there is an extended version of
the low degree conjecture which says
that degree d polynomials are as
powerful as
roughly n to the d time algorithms maybe
up to some log factors in the exponent
or a more concrete version of that is is
here if the degree is
n to the delta this kind of corresponds
to algorithms of
x sub exponential runtime uh e to the n
to the delta
and so there's some cases where you can
even pin down the exact
the exact value of delta that is needed
in order to succeed
and this tells you how much sub
exponential time should be needed
for the problem
um okay but for the rest of the talk i
will
mostly focus on just the polynomial
deciding whether there should be a
polynomial time algorithm or not
so i'll be imagining the degree to be
something logarithmic or maybe slightly
larger
okay
so let me try to show you how the proof
should go now
so we want to compute this thing this
advantage
and so uh how should we do it
so uh for simplicity let's focus on the
case where the null distribution is
uniform plus minus ones so i could
imagine
thinking about planted clique but now
i'm just
saying that i use minus one for a
non-edge and
plus one for an edge right so
here there's like n choose two variables
alex that is yeah another question
actually galena you are still muted that
is okay anyway i'll already date
what if capital d is of order one
if capital d is order one yeah so
it depends a bit on the problem for some
problems we do know
that there are constant degree
polynomials that can solve them
in the easy regime but there are other
problems
where it seems that you really need a
logarithmic
degree in order to solve them so
you know you could you can you can study
the power of constant degree polynomials
but whether it really means something
about computational hardness is a bit
questionable really if you want to have
strong evidence that something is
actually hard you should rule out
polynomials of degree
at least logarithmic
okay so what are we gonna do for this
proof so the proof
uh is gonna be quite straightforward
really we're just going to kind of
write out what f is uh as a polynomial
like
the fourier expansion if you like in the
coefficients and we're just going to
see what happens when we write advantage
in that form and we'll be able to kind
of solve everything explicitly
um okay so what am i doing here i'm
taking my f and just expanding it
in the monomial basis right
uh y to the s is just a
shorthand for the product of those
values
so here if we're thinking about um
planted clique we should imagine that m
is like and choose two because these are
there are variables one for each edge
uh okay and so these coefficients f hat
are what sort of define
uh determine the polynomial
and what's going to be important here is
that these
uh these y sub s these fourier
characters
are orthonormal with respect to the null
distribution q in this sense
this is sort of why i picked q to be
plus minus 1 instead of 0
1 is because this orthonormality will be
very useful
and so let's just write out what the
numerator and denominator are
in this right so here's the numerator of
this advantage
let's write out what f is expand it this
blue equation
right and move the expectation inside
and we just get
something that looks like this and i
want to interpret this as
an inner product right i want to think
of this as an inner product between our
f-hat vector
so i'm thinking of f-hat as being sort
of
a um you know a vector
indexed by all the sets of size
d
and it's the inner product of that thing
against c
where c is just this part so this is
what i'm calling c
sub s okay
and then for the denominator right this
uh
expectation under q of f squared
well because of ortho orthonormality
this uh works out
nicely and i get just the sum of squares
of the
fourier coefficients right this is just
like plancharelle's theorem
and so i can write this just as sort of
the norm of f
of f hat okay
and so what does this mean now
so now i've rewritten the problem in a
form that looks uh much easier
to handle the problem boils bound to
maximizing over these vectors
f hat of you know the inner product
between f and something divided by
its norm and of course we all know the
answer to this right i should just take
f to b
c
and so if i plug in what that should be
i just get that the norm of c is the
answer
and then if i go remind myself what c
actually was
i get this very explicit formula for the
advantage
okay and to compute this i just need to
be able to
compute the expectation of one of these
uh one of these orthogonal polynomials
under the planted measure
um is this okay so this was uh
sort of straightforward i hope uh yeah
let me know if
uh any questions at this point i think
there's a raised hand in the audience
but i'm not a
i'm not a host so i can't unmute them um
yeah but i think okay i kind of mute but
this was
from itamar from the previous talk
okay sorry
so i cannot allow him to talk but
okay maybe i will go on then if there's
no
questions um okay so the way i presented
this was maybe slightly different than
usual so let me also make a few remarks
that sort of interpret this
result and compare it a bit to classical
statistics
so if you just want to distinguish
between two distributions
um in you know information theoretically
without any
uh computational restrictions the best
thing you can do is the likelihood ratio
likelihood ratio is this dpdq which you
know a little more explicitly
is just you know what's the probability
um that y occurs
under the distribution p
divided by the probability that y would
occur
under q right so y is is whatever
major whatever matrix i observe i just
compute how likely would that have
happened under b
versus how likely would happen at their
q um
and it's sort of not hard to believe
that this should be kind of the optimal
way to
decide which one it was
and it turns out what we showed in the
last slide is that the best degree d
test is actually just uh you take the
likelihood ratio and you project it
onto the space of degree d polynomials
um what do i mean by projection exactly
more specifically it's orthogonal
projection with respect to this
inner product that is defined in terms
of
q and so this is often called the low
degree
likelihood ratio this thing here
um which we write whoops
right we write this uh subscript d to
mean
projection onto the subspace of the
degree d functions
uh and also the advantage right this
value we wanted to compute
is uh is just the norm of the low degree
likelihood ratio where the norm is the
norm
associated with that inner product which
is also kind of just the second moment
so many of you are probably familiar
with just the norm of the likelihood
ratio
without any low degree projection
this is just um
one plus the chi-squared divergence
between uh p and q
right or in other words this if you are
writing uh yeah yeah sorry oh is it
lagging of it okay
uh yeah so this uh
right so this chi squared divergence is
something you can look at to tell
whether
two things are statistically
indistinguishable
and so this low degree likelihood ratio
is sort of just a
natural low degree analog of this
to reconcile this with what happened in
the last slide if you
are curious how to see that this is a
projection
you can think about uh what are the
fourier coefficients of
l well to extract a fourier coefficient
the s co fourier coefficient i should
just sort of integrate
l against the appropriate basis function
which means um
uh right to get this expression but now
remember that
this likelihood ratio is dpdq which sort
of lets me change measure from
from q to p and so i get this
this next expression here
but comparing this to what we found in
the last slide well we found the same
thing but just restricted to
um sets of size at most d
so this is the sense in which our
optimal f star was just a projection of
the likelihood ratio
um okay any questions about this
so just to give you a sense of you know
after carrying out this approach
what are the types of results you can
get
um right imagine this fairly general
setting where we have an additive
gaussian model
meaning that this
let's see y is going to be oops
y is going to be in
r to the m and it's going to have iid
sorry it's gonna be y is x plus c
where z is just uh
z is iid gaussian
and then x is sort of anything x is
drawn from
from whatever prior you like which would
be some kind of low rank
matrix or tensor or whatever
so in this very general setting you can
use the method i described before to
write down this general
formula for the advantage and it sort of
just depends on
on this x and x prime is two independent
copies of the signal
looking at the overlap between two of
them
so if you somehow understand the
uh the overlap between two random
independent copies of the signal this uh
lets you
get good bounds on this a similar
situation
uh setup is this rademacher model where
y is
plus minus ones and again an x is drawn
from any distribution
and sort of once you draw x the entries
of y are conditionally independent and
their
mean is given by uh x so this captures
things like planted clique
uh and the same formula is true there
but with an inequality
so these are some general purpose
results you can plug into
a wide variety of uh problems if they
have this form
so alex just perhaps you you mentioned
that just for clarity these expectations
are
with respect to the null model right
uh the expectation here in the formula
yeah
yeah so this is just with respect to the
prior
so it's with respect to whatever prior x
is drawn
from in the planted model okay
okay so just to quickly recap the
detection setting
what we showed is that given some
distributions p and q that we want to
distinguish
you can compute sort of in a
straightforward way by linear algebra
this thing i called the advantage
also known as the low degree likelihood
ratio um
to do this we needed to know orthogonal
polynomials with respect to
q um typically this is this is
easy to do if q has independent
coordinates
and so and to predict whether a problem
was easy or hard we just looked at
whether this thing
blows up or not as n goes to infinity
hey alex can i ask a
i'd be happy to wait tell me if you want
to wait to the end but
i'm trying to understand why d should be
log n so it's certainly true
that if i have kind of an arbitrary
polynomial
of n variables well then they're about n
to the d
possible terms and it would take me
maybe n to the d time
to compute them um
but if we're thinking about planted
clique then by the problem has an
enormous amount of symmetry
and certainly i can compute in
polynomial time
highly symmetric polynomials of much
higher degree
than than log n so
especially for these random problems
where any algorithm would presumably
have a great deal
of symmetry because the problem does why
should i believe that log n
is the relevant degree for easy versus
heart
yeah that's a good question um
right i mean yeah there's some question
as to whether the login is sort of
needed
like oftentimes if you're in the easy
regime
this advantage will blow up even if you
have a constant degree or maybe a
slightly
super constant degree polynomial i would
say the main reason we focus on
log n is because um
is because it's nice to rule out all the
class of all possible spectral methods
like uh typically the way you can solve
a problem is uh
by making some kind of spectral method
be it just uh
the original matrix you're given or the
non-backtracking walk or whatever
and this will have some kind of spectral
gap and so
if you you need degree log n to in order
to sort of
compute this top eigenvector eigenvalue
and so for the lower bounds it's nice to
rule out things of a degree at least log
n so that we can
rule out all of these types of methods
um but you're right the the questions um
you know
the amount of time it takes to compute a
certain polynomial
is is not really clear like some
polynomials might have a special
structure the less can be computed more
easily and so on
does that uh how does that help yeah i
guess i'm also
you know you mentioned before message
passing algorithms that have some
non-linearity like if
if each step of a message passing
algorithm is some rational function
uh of the previous messages then the
degree of the polynomial would grow
exponentially in the number of
iterations
and so a polynomial number of iterations
could correspond to an
exponentially high degree polynomial
so anyway i mean yeah
yeah for so for these amp algorithms we
usually imagine that
the non-linear nonlinear part can be
approximated by a constant degree
polynomial
and then typically you only need a
constant number of iterations
in order to solve the problem in the
easy regime
so this corresponds to a constant degree
polynomial uh there are some other
settings where maybe you need to
initialize it starting with a spectral
method which takes log number of
iterations
and then do a constant number of rounds
of amp
um so for the for the examples we sort
of know about for the existing instances
of amp i do think these can be
represented as polynomials of degree uh
again but you're right that like if i if
i
take some arbitrary iteration and start
iterating this
the degree will blow up exponentially so
i need to be
a bit careful yeah
um all right should i move on to
recovery
so okay so what is recovery so for
recovery it will be
um here's a good example to think about
it's a very simple problem called
planted submatrix
okay so perhaps i'll also ask a question
since now
i thought you is there a a
will you state a theorem or a lemma
because it says
advantage small of one implies
you know this can be treated advantage
divergence
diverging means it's it's not tractable
and you say predicts but is there you
know can you state a lambo there
in particular you know your upper
bounding total variation
seems to me by by chi-square and so
yeah right i mean something
it's some kind of a computational
chi-squared
um right so testing you should upper
bound
you should have a computational version
of total variation right
right i mean i don't know maybe exactly
how to
state that i mean one one version of
is is that like if this uh
you know if this thing is
is bounded
you know then there does not exist
a degree d
um polynomial
f for which for which you can sort of
threshold it in the following sense like
you know expectation under planted
of f should be at least one plus epsilon
whereas the probability under
q of being like
smaller than one is is quite big
um but there's one catch to this is that
we need to take delta to be some
explicit
thing which is roughly this
but uh you know the question is the the
the other direction
oh the other direction if n diverges
oh yeah yeah no that direction is just
false actually
okay um if if l diverges it could just
be diverging because of a very rare
event in the planted model
yeah this is what i was talking i see
okay sorry so i misunderstood
um yeah so the other direction is not
really a theorem but you know for the
problems
yeah so i'm thinking more of this as a
framework for lower bounds
but for like for all the problems we all
the natural problems we know about
in the easy regime you can prove uh you
know a stronger thing
about polynomials that they really do
distinguish it
uh properly okay alex and not just in
this sense
yeah there is another question from the
audience from anna
whom i am muted she says
on the previous slides what does it mean
that this prediction are
quote unquote correct oh yeah i meant to
uh
say that by correct here i just mean
that it uh
coincides with the best known algorithms
so of course we don't really know
the true computational thresholds but
it's uh consistent with the best known
things and sort of a widely
believed conjectures yeah
that's a good point
okay so moving on to recovery
so i want to talk about this planted
sub-matrix question
which can be um
simply stated like this you know you
have this sort of n by n
matrix and there's a planted sub matrix
of sorry
of mean lambda whereas the rest is just
mean zero gaussians okay and the planted
sub matrix has size that's like
about rho times n
so there's a you know small matrix of
elevated mean
and so more formally you can write y as
this
signal plus noise where the signal is
this rank one part
um and the noise is gaussian okay
so let me get rid of this now so we can
ask both the
recovery and detection question
detection just means distinguish
uh this planted thing but
between uh iid gaseon recovery means
actually find
v so v we think of as the indicator
vector for where the
planted structure is
okay so right why am i making such a
distinction between detection and
recovery
so if uh
what's true in this problem is also sort
of true generally
most of the time is that if you can do
recovery then you can do detection
in the sense that there's a polynomial
time reduction
right hopefully this is sort of clear
that like if you can
recover a planted structure you should
then at least be able to tell whether it
was even there in the first place
if you'd like sort of a formal
reduction you know how do you
if suppose i can recover how do i
distinguish well you try running your
recovery algorithm to get some vector
and then you just kind of check how good
that vector is
and if you're actually in the planted
model you'll cover the true thing and
you'll check it and you'll see that it's
good
whereas in the null distribution no
matter what v-hat you
come up with it's not going to pass this
test
right so if we want to argue that we so
taking the contrapositive of this last
statement
if we want to argue that recovery is
hard
we could just instead argue that
detection is hard right if we prove a
detection lower bound
then recovery is hard and so we're done
right
the issue is that this problem and some
other problems actually have a detection
recovery gap
meaning that detection and recovery are
not equally hard
and we'd like to understand this so
here's sort of a picture of
the situation here if i take
a signal to noise parameter lambda
there's sort of these two important
thresholds
you know which happen to occur at
this value and
this value although that's not terribly
important
so um at first
you know both detection and recovery are
hard
then detection is easy but recovery is
hard
and then both of them are easy
right this is all the computational
thresholds if i care about the
information theoretic thresholds these
are all uh way out here somewhere and
may or may not be different for uh
detection versus recovery um okay so do
we see what's happening here
the the sort of uh
regime of most interest for this part of
the talk is right in here
where detection is easy but we think
recovery is hard
and we'd like to show hardness of
recovery
right so we cannot just use this we
can't just use
this method right since our detection is
easy we need to find some other way to
argue that recovery is hard
and uh right so roughly why are
why are these thresholds happening
detection
becomes easy just by taking the sum of
all the entries of the matrix
if you notice that the matrix is
slightly positively biased
on the other hand the best way to do
recovery that we know of
is to is used in using the top
eigenvector
i guess technically i should mention
that this is
only the picture for a certain regime of
uh of row values of the sparsity
so there's only a detection recovery gap
for a certain
sparsity values and not others
okay so is this kind of clear
so um so how do we define
this recovery problem
right in terms of low degree polynomials
we'd like to estimate v1 using a low
degree polynomial
so what is v1 v1 is just like the first
entry of the planted signal
and kind of by symmetry it's sufficient
to just
figure out whether the first entry is
either in the planted matrix or not
right if i could figure that out then i
could do also do the rest sort of
the same way all right so i want a
polynomial that takes in the whole
matrix and
outputs sort of a zero one value that
tells me whether the first entry is in
the
signal and sort of the natural way to
measure this
is by the low degree minimum mean
squared error
right this is sort of exactly what you
would imagine it's the
minimum mean squared error among all
degree d polynomials
uh it will actually be technically a bit
nicer to work with something else which
we call the maximum correlation
so this correlation is maybe look
similar to the
expressions we looked at for detection
um right it's sort of
think of it as you know the it's like
right this top is sort of the
inner product between uh you know how
how well are you correlating with with
v1 and
normalized in the appropriate way
and these two are just uh equivalent
it's not hard to check that the minimum
mean squared error and the maximum
correlation are just related by a simple
formula
so from now on we'll just think about
how to control the correlation
okay so how do we try to prove such a
thing
well for an upper bound we'd like to
prove
um to show the problem is hard we like
to we would like to prove it upper bound
on the correlation
right and so okay what should we try we
should try to do the same thing as
detection right so just expand out the
polynomial in terms of all its
coefficients
and start uh plugging it in you know
we'll see that the numerator is again
just the inner product between f hat and
and something
but the denominator now will be a little
bit different
so what's important here and what maybe
i glossed over
is that you know this now that i'm
talking about recovery there is no such
thing as a null model
i'm talking about the planted
distribution on both the top and the
bottom here
and so these basis functions are no
longer
orthogonal with respect to the planted
measure the planted measure is
is something complicated and we don't
really know how to get
orthogonal polynomials for it at least i
don't
and so you know we're going to have to
expand this out and get all these
cross terms and we'll get some quadratic
function of
of this f hat
okay and so well what happens next
i can write down the correlation again
in sort of a nice linear algebraic way
and you know this does have a linear
algebraic solution
but it involves this kind of nasty
inverse of some matrix
and this does not seem easy to handle
at least i have no idea how to handle
this
there's some like explicit matrix m and
you need to find its inverse
um and uh maybe someone out there can do
it but uh it seems
it seems difficult
right so and if we knew the orthogonal
polynomials for the planted measure we
could also
do it by uh by expanding f in that basis
instead of this one but we also
don't know that so it seems like we're
kind of a bit stuck here
but let me show you how we actually can
make progress here so here's the key
idea for how to prove
these uh detection results i mean sorry
recovery
results we're gonna
do a bound by jensen's inequality in
order to simplify
things a little bit but we're only going
to apply jensen's inequality to the
signal part
and not the noise part so remember that
y
is like has a signal and a noise
and so um this first step is just sort
of expanding
that definition of y explicitly
and then in the second step i've used
jensen's inequality to move
the expectation over x uh
inside the square
okay so this is certainly a thing i can
do
um but why is this a good idea
so a couple of miracles sort of happen
here that
not sure that we fully understand but
um you know one reason why this gives
you an okay bound is that
in the hard regime which is the regime
we care about here f basically just
depends on
z right the problem is this the signal
x is like too small for any low degree
polynomial to be able to see
somehow and so you can think of f as
basically just being a function of the
noise
but if f is basically just a function of
the noise then
you know it doesn't matter whether i
move this x in or out
so this is some intuition why this bound
is reasonably tight
no you certainly would not get a good
bound if you did jensen to both the
signal and the noise
you would get just infinity in fact
but sort of the second miracle that
happens here is that this actually
simplifies things enough to find a
closed form expression
and i won't attempt to show you the full
details of that
but i'll kind of just sketch what ends
up happening
is that here's the type of expression
you get you get
the inner product of f with something on
top and on the bottom you get something
with a nasty matrix again except it's
actually not such a nasty matrix it
turns out to be
upper triangular and then if you solve
this by linear algebra
you know you have an m inverse but since
m is upper triangular you can just
invert this explicitly and so this
somehow
gives you an explicit way to
to handle this this problem
okay so
here is just sort of uh to give you a
taste of what the result kind of looks
like
if we again look at this additive
gaussian model and we take
small x to be the scalar value that i
want to recover
so think of this as like the v1
um then here's some formula that upper
bounds the correlation
it turns out to depend on these joint
cumulants of different
collections of the random variables
along with the true
signal so here s
is like if y is in
r to the m s is uh
it's actually a multi multi subset
multi-subset of m and if you don't know
what accumulant is
uh don't worry too much this is just to
tell you that there is
some explicit formula that you can get
and uh as a result you can get uh some
type of bounds for the planted submatrix
recovery problem that i talked about
before
um i won't spend too much time on this
but basically in the hard regime
we show that the mean squared error is
like
is trivial trivial meaning what the same
thing you would get is
you just took like a constant function
or the best possible constant function
right so this is meaning no degree
polynomials can't do anything
whereas in the in the easy regime they
succeed
getting a small mean squared error wait
alex i have a question
like i thought you just proved an upper
bound on the correlation
but you you're deriving the coronary
both
lower bounds and other bonds on the mmc
like what happened here
yeah that's a good point so actually
only one of these only
the uh only the lower bound uses the
formula i wrote
above if you want to show that low
degree polynomials succeed in the easy
regime
what you can do is just take an existing
algorithm that you know works
like power iteration or whatever and
just uh show directly that it works
yeah cool yeah good good point
um okay
so let me pause again if there's any
questions so let me try to
talk a bit about optimization since
we're kind of short on time maybe i will
skip this example and just do the second
one
so this is about the spherical spin
glass
problem which we heard about earlier um
but let me instead just talk about uh
maximum independent set
which is a different random optimization
problem
right so here the setting is quite
different we're imagining that the input
is just a random
thing like a random graph and here the
goal is to find as big an independent
set
as you can but there's no planted
solution
okay so we take a sparse erdos-renyi
graph where the average degree is d
and we want to uh maximize
we want to find a big independent set so
what do we know about this
well the opt meaning the the size of the
actual
maximum independent set is you know is
something
and alg meaning the the best known
algorithms
achieve only half of that
right so if i'm plotting here sort of
the objective value f
s you know here's the true optimum
algorithms can only get uh sort of this
far
that we know of so this this is sort of
what you can think of as the easy
easy regime here
and what we can show is that uh no low
degree polynomial can get past
well some other threshold that's sort of
in the middle here
so what this result is showing is that
it's hard to do
any better than this right and so
middle we don't know yet
and so what does uh okay in order to
really state this theorem i have to
describe what exactly does it mean for a
low degree polynomial to find a large
independent set
right it's maybe not so clear
alex may jump in for a second there was
a question
from galena to remind what independence
said is i
intended to type in the answer but
instead press wrong button so could you
just remind
oh good point yeah thanks sorry i didn't
mention that
so an independent set if i have some
graph an independent set
is a set of vertices that has no edges
between them right so if here's a graph
with a bunch of edges
an independent set you know it can have
edges going
out but there is no edge between two
vertices in the independent set does
that make sense
yeah sorry some people call this a
stable set
right yeah
um okay sounds good
okay so let me try to explain what it
you know how should we define what it
means for a polynomial to find a large
independent set
so here i'm imagining a polynomial that
takes in the graph
right and outputs uh a vector and i'd
like that vector to be
basically the indicator vector for a big
independent set
okay and so what how do i define success
well first you know i'd like this f to
output values that are basically zero
and one
so let's say that you know it outputs
things that are either
close to zero or close to one you know
for most
for most values of i
and then i interpret these ones i
interpret the large ones as sort of an
independent set
so once i take all of those i want that
to be almost an independent set of sort
of the
desired size
and you know i've been a bit informal
here but we again allow it to make a
small number say like an epsilon
fraction of errors
it's allowed to mess up a few times and
we sort of just
give it a small amount of leeway
okay and so what is this theorem saying
this is saying that no polynomial
can reach the subjective level
right you think of these two as being
the definition of success
this is a no polynomial a low degree
polynomial achieves success
with like a particular explicit
high probability bound right so it's not
just uh part of the definition of
success needs to
require that you succeed with reasonably
high probability
but this is pretty mild in the sense
that you know in the easy regime
if you want an algorithm that just gets
up to here you can succeed with like
basically exponentially small
probability
and okay maybe you are concerned about
this value being not the optimal one
um but actually it turns out with a bit
more work we can improve this
but this is not posted yet um you can
prove it to the the actual optimal value
of one so really we now know that
we have sort of a sharp result where
it's hard everywhere here easy
everywhere here
and so low degree polynomials
um you know pin down exactly this
conjectured
uh value you can get up to
um okay
so maybe i can ask a question
um do you think that there's hope of
improving this uh
probability statement like you know this
is ruling out estimators
of exponentially good probability but
may maybe i would want to also uh
rule out you know estimators that only
succeed with probability one minus
polynomial in n
yeah i agree with you that this would be
quite nice if we could
you know remove this if we could just
say 1 minus little 01 here or something
i don't have any ideas for how to do
this because the proof
does sort of rely on union bounding over
the algorithm succeeding at a lot of
different inputs and so on
um so yeah i don't i don't have any
ideas for how to do this but
i agree it would be very nice okay
can i ask a sort of related questions so
i i haven't
i mean i i'll i'll try and go read this
paper but
one of the ways to prove these bounds is
by constructing some sort of
planted model right like like some sort
of quiet planting
um but then where then do we need
this error probability to correspond to
the probability that the unplanted model
is in fact like the planted model or or
is this not about
planting at all
so one i mean one way you could try to
prove something like this
would be by constructing what you could
call like an unplanted model
like if i can construct you know the
naturally in a random graph
this is the biggest independent set if i
could construct a planted model where
the biggest independent set is actually
this
meaning i've somehow removed all the big
independent sets
then this would be some way i could try
to argue this type of thing
sort of anti anti-planting
yeah so this idea of anti-planting is
something that
we thought about a lot particularly with
the fonzo
but yeah i think it's fair to say we
have no idea how to do this
anti-planting
so the proof that i'll show you we're
kind of out of time but the proof i
would have shown you is uh is totally
different
um so i know we're at the end of the
time
if i in a couple minutes i can maybe
sketch the high level idea of why this
uh of how to prove this is that okay
you have 60 seconds okay
um okay so you know first maybe you try
the same proof as before
this turns out to fail horribly um
because you'd have some
you know instead of just having some
linear quadratic function in your
f hat you end up having like a fourth
degree polynomial or something terrible
um so basically instead the proof is
totally different from what we saw
before
it uses two things the first one is
stability of low degree polynomials
it turns out load of degree polynomials
have kind of a nice property where
in some sense like if if you perturb the
input a little bit the output
on average won't change so much
and we combine that with something
called the overlap gap property
so this is something that um you know
has been studied a lot in its own right
there are in fact many different
variants of the overlap gap property out
there
and the particular variant that we use
is is most
directly influenced by these uh these
papers here
um and the overlap gap property is some
structural property
of um of near optimal sets
that basically prevents any stability
any stable algorithm from from
succeeding
so i know i'm sort of out of time so
maybe i should skip this proof
um and just wrap up by showing some
possible future directions and open
problems
so thank you all
okay thank you alex
okay so there is a couple of questions
perhaps i read them
and there was also a couple of questions
that i missed from the q and a
earlier because i was i started
following the talk actually i'm just
kidding and
so there is a question from jason asking
what is the meaning of a stable
algorithm
i guess he's referring to your last uh
you know sketch of the proof
from right uh okay maybe this is an
invitation to uh actually go over this
slide
um here's the particular definition of a
stable algorithm that
we use here so by stable i mean
um you know imagine y is some kind of
independent is like my graph which has
iid entries and i'm going to make this
interpolation path
by you know starting with some random
graph
and at each step i resample um
you know i resample one of the edges so
with the first step i resample edge one
then i resample edge two
and so on and so m is just the total
number of uh
edges or total number of bits so i
resample every edge
once and
um okay and f is imagine f is a as a
low-degree
polynomial that takes these things as
input
and i'm going to call one of these one
step of this process bad
if the output of f changes a lot right
so remember f outputs a vector
so we look at how much does the output
of f change between two adjacent steps
if this is sort of big compared to
the typical size of the things that f
outputs
then this is called a bad edge and here
is really the
the key effect that i'm calling
stability
that when you draw this random
interpolation path there is a
non-trivial probability
that none of the edges are bad so not
like high probability but like
some some decent probability
that uh that f sort of acts
smoothly along that whole path and never
has a big jump
so this is the meaning of stable that we
use
okay so there is another question from
anna that actually i
uh unmuted so anna if you want to talk
directly
um sure yes i was wondering um what is
known about the
relationship between the um
degree of the planting method and the
degree of the
um of the algorithm to actually find the
clique or other planted structure
uh okay so you're imagine you're
thinking about like the degree
of the actual uh the distribution itself
yeah if it's like planted by an of an
adversary or something like
is there yeah what's not about the
relationship of the degree of
the yeah the album the adversary is
using
and what's necessary to find the planted
structure
uh if you had an adversary that can sort
of
use some low degree polynomial to
somehow decide
where to plant it so i mean one thing i
should maybe mention is that
for all of these problems i'm imagining
that you have kind of a fully specified
random model
i'm not thinking about problems where
maybe an adversary is
corrupting edges so i'm wondering about
what is the
like what is the input to your adversary
oh the adversary observes the graph
the sort of the graph and then decides
where to add something else maybe using
um yeah i think i don't know
i don't think i have a good answer to
this off the top of my head
yeah i've typically not thought about uh
yeah most of the planted models i've
thought about are just sort of
very well specified like they're sort of
i guess constant degree polynomials
in whatever underlying iid things are
generated
um yeah sorry not to be more hopeful
okay thanks
more questions um i have a technical one
alex you said that you pushed the limit
to one plus epsilon from one plus one
over square root two right
i mean i don't know how you're going to
talk about this but just as a quick
like do you prove like do you use the
multi-over laptop property
that like from mustache and berlin
yeah it's something along those lines
yeah instead of
looking at just uh forbidden overlaps
between
two independent sets you have to look at
forbidden structures that involve many
independent sets
okay okay make sense thank you okay
there was a
question from sophie that actually i
unmuted so yeah if you want to yeah so
on this on the slide that is on uh
you're talking about this interpolation
path
which i guess has some order in which
you look at the edges
does the order matter is it fixed in the
fonts
yeah that's a good point um yeah it's
fixed in advance but it's
arbitrary it turns out to not matter
or not be important for the proof so
fix any arbitrary order of the edges
um yeah i know i didn't get to showing
the other half of this proof so it's
maybe unclear how this is being used
but uh happy to
explain it sometime later i guess
i wanted to make one or two comments
andre
possible sure so uh one i i thought uh
regarding silly's question i thought uh
we could tolerate inverse polynomial
error if the degree is
constant certainly for spin models i
thought also for independence
am i wrong alex am i uh yeah you're
right that sort of i did simplify things
a little bit
but really there's some there's more of
like a trade-off between
this degree and this error probability
um and it's something like
it's something like this
log yeah um yeah i think there's
in for independent set there's maybe a
login here
yeah yeah so for the pspin model the
proof was a bit different and this had
slightly better parameters like for the
pspin model
we really could get a
just a little o of one here if we were
looking at
constant degree polynomials um but
that's not quite true for
independent set i think
so i and i wanted to say thinking about
this
stability properties it's not it's not
surprising that
that stability is uh sort of shows up in
in
in in this in negative results if you
uh think about in a complete somewhat
different uh
world of of showing uh hardness for the
circuit complexity so it's known that
low degree low depth circuits cannot
compute some functions like like parity
or more complicated functions like
independent sets and things like that
and the method uses the so-called hasta
switching dilemma
which which in a nutshell is certain
type of stability result it says that if
you perturb your instance just a little
bit
then this low degree circuits will not
entirely change their output drastically
so that uh somehow is also built in
in this argument so that brings me to
some
question to alex and and others maybe
this low degree
bounce can be lifted to high degree
bounds but with a bounce on the number
of characters that you use
in your uh estimator so think about
going back to your very first model
planted click
you look at the f f depends f has any
degree
monomials in it but you're limited to
use only polynomially many characters
it's probably is doable to show that
this
is not still not distinguishing hit and
click from
non-hitting click perhaps so then one
can take it further and start looking at
these circuits
of polynomials so that would bring it a
bit closer to the classical computer
science
literature i think would be really
interesting
thanks yeah
more i comments one comment along those
lines
in in this area that david's referring
to of uh
you know low depth circuits and
polynomials and
it's been a long time since i've i've
paid
attention to that area but i remember
these interesting results where
like fourier analytic arguments you have
to kind of you sometimes have to
cleverly choose
which finite field you do for a analysis
over
right sort of a souped-up version of how
you chose to represent edges as
plus one minus one instead of zero and
one but
you know for various circuit uh
complexity classes sometimes people say
oh well
we'll use f3 at this level and then f2
at that level and so on
there can be some delicacy there where
if you
do this over one field you get things
that are
very sparse or very low degree but
things blow up if you use
the wrong field somehow so
for some problems there may be some art
in how we
uh yeah how we how we define
the degree of a polynomial
i didn't know that i but one the only
thing that i know is that the logic
load up circuits cannot distinct this uh
distinguish the hidden click problem a
result by rosman that i wish was
mentioned more often than it is uh
because i think it's
it's a really nice work but that one i
think is using the vanilla
uh fourier expansion
plus minus once with biased probability
because it's a hidden click in a sparse
random graph model
gentlemen before this degenerates in a
circuit complexity conference
which would be i wouldn't mind
or some of us wouldn't be
good on our cv
no if there isn't no other questions
close the session or close my connection
at least
okay if not we thank again alex and all
the speakers
that wonderful job and
i'll see you tomorrow i guess for me